this is robin
she is two years 10 months old
this is peter he is tears 11 months old
this is daryl he is two years 10 months
old
[Music]
robin peter and daryl were hospitalized
at different times
each was in the same ward
each for minor surgery
robin surgery is for an umbilical hernia
[Music]
peter's surgery is to be a hernia repair
if you sit here you'll hear your name
being called want to hear peter's name
all the children will have brief
examinations before being admitted to
the ward
daryl's operation is for the removal of
a rectal polyp would you come around
here and hold him for me please i want
him to just lie on his back
daryl's aunt has come to help his mother
with the hospital procedures
the family is from puerto rico and
daryl's mother has difficulty with
english
daryl understands only a few english
phrases and talks only in spanish
visiting hours are from two to six but
on the morning of admission the parents
are asked to stay until after the
resident has examined the children
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
daryl's aunt is showing the nurse a
diaper that he likes to hold when he
goes to bed
[Applause]
robin
did you bring your pajamas with you
no no you didn't bring them together no
well how about i go and get you a pair
of pajamas
and you put them on
and then i'll take you in and i'll get
you away and see how tall you are
okay okay
okay
i'll be back
do you want to put on your newsflippers
and show me how they look
[Music]
no
okay let's put on your slippers
[Music]
and that nurse can get you a lollipop if
you do what you tell you
what color do you like
peter
do you want a lollipop a red one
can you put your pajamas on for me first
okay
uh
[Music]
[Music]
boys
[Music]
[Music]
how old are you robin
two got any brothers and sisters
do you
are they home
do you have any that go to school
yeah
how old are they
[Music]
just going to hold your hand
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
a medical student questions peter's
mother on the sun porch next to the ward
you should be feeding yourself
what about in the family how does he get
along with his brothers and sisters
he gets along very well with them for
the simple reason that they give him
whatever he wants because when he starts
screaming
have his temper tantrum then
you say he has more temper tantrums than
the rest of the children
yes
one a day or more
yeah i'd say two or three days
especially when you take them out to the
store a place like alexander's and throw
himself all over the place
daryl's father stationed in washington
got leave to visit daryl in the hospital
[Music]
and how's your health been
good
and your husband 37.
and his health okay
any brothers and sisters oh yes you have
two brothers two brothers and how old
are they one is eight
and everyone's bad
and how are they
fine
does she eat
all foods or is there anything that she
is too much
robin's mother had also told the nurse
that robin prefers the bottle to eat it
see i was kind to the health station the
doctor told me that she needed to be
operated because it was getting large
and long
let me ask you a question
[Music]
yeah let me ask you a question can you
be a good boy long enough to let me look
at your chest and back
huh
hop up in the bed and take your shirt
off like a good no needles today okay
[Music]
fall still
right back on your back
lay back on your butt
keep let me hear you pop
cross on your feet
cough
cough
can you open your mouth and stick your
tongue sit up for me
open your mouth
i'm not gonna have a stick ah can you
stay out for me
stick out your tongue real big and say
yeah okay honey come on would you like a
nice lollipop
[Music]
okay can we put this little stick in for
a minute just to see
kind of hold
[Music]
look look can you show me your happened
to her
no sorry she could use a dentist she's
got very bad teeth there they're all
rotting away and it's going to affect
her other teeth when they come in later
uh she's going to have an effect from
that
[Music]
[Music]
can i listen to your chest
okay let's see now
let me take a listen okay
you want to go like that okay you stay
like that for me all right
[Music]
that's good okay sit up for me again
can you sit up oh boy
oh [ __ ]
oh okay that's good
okay let me see
okay
[Music]
robin's mother is leaving for the day
she told robin she will be right back
[Music]
[Music]
push your foot in come on push your foot
push your foot in okay
oh good girl
[Music]
i didn't get any more left in that
bottle have you
[Music]
tomorrow
[Music]
peter's father has come for the
afternoon
whatever you want you want a big bunny
[Music]
do you want some drugs
mommy has to go home and make fluffer
and i'll be
[Music]
all right we'll here here for a while
okay
[Music]
robin's mother did not come back as she
promised
[Music]
do you want to go to sleep
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
daryl's father is trying to teach him
english
right
i'm going to learn english
[Music]
let me go to school right
can you go to school
a sacred heart
[Music]
all the other children want to go home
too and they will go home just as soon
as they're better
we want you to come home with us but you
have to wait here for a day or so
and daddy will be in to see you tomorrow
pete
mommy will be here
[Music]
and tomorrow wanna go
[Music]
okay cause home pants are wet
i'll change your pants
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
peter is having dinner on the sun porch
what is this it's pudding pudding with
whipped cream
i'll tell you what we'll do i'll feed
you one spoon and then you feed
yourself for one
let me
[Music]
was that good too
this is dinner
why don't you want to eat yeah
wish i had a big thick hamburger i said
yui stretching out on the grass what i
wouldn't give for a hot dog said dewey
dropping down beside him
pizza for me said louis lou the other
one is louie he likes pizza
[Music]
[Music]
okay kiss daddy
don't go
huh
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
hello
[Music]
because he's going to miss you sooner or
later right i just didn't know what the
best way to handle it
[Music]
now
i have to take a phone call
and i have to go and
do some other things but i'll be back as
soon as i can
i'll bring some candy and what else what
would you like
candy
bubble gum sure okay i'll get you some
bubble gum you want chocolate candy
big box oil box
okay
now
[Music]
[Music]
the mother of another patient brings
daryl toys to cheer him up
[Applause]
robin tell me which color you want
you want this color
this one a volunteer you pick it up
that one
okay
you want to hang on to that one what are
you going to do with it
you want to make it into a circle
like this
[Music]
no no it's not going to hurt
did i say it was
do you understand me do you understand
me yes or no
medical student is examining daryl
you talk
you always three years old you talk
what do you think we should do with this
you want to make something else you do
what would you like to know
should we make a chocolate cake
okay let's see what we can do
after the examination daryl looks for
his friends parents who have left and
for his diaper from home which someone
put in the hospital laundry
don't try
you know asleep okay well don't cry then
because if you cry gonna put you in bed
all right
daryl
come here
you want to be a good boy
you not why
you want to go to bed
you do huh you're on the bed
that's where you go when you're
surprised
yes
[Music]
the children are given injections an
hour before they are taken to the
operating room
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay that's all
no more
no more okay
okay
[Music]
i have to give you a little pinch your
leg okay
and it's going to make it sleepy it's
going to make it really sleek
there's a band-aid
you can put on it after you put the
little pinch on your legs
[Applause]
[Music]
can you hold real still
can you hold your leg real still
[Music]
but there's have to stay in bed
daryl's surgery is scheduled later in
the morning
he's not allowed any breakfast
[Music]
[Music]
i don't speak spanish
and then when you wake up they'll be
taking care of you
you're gonna cry again
let's take it easy
you're a big girl you know
yeah
the doctor's not going to hurt you
you're going to be sensitive all the
time
no
yes you are
i'll put you to sleep we'll give you
some medicine and make you go to sleep
yes don't you want to go to sleep
[Music]
is
[Music]
i want you to hold your leg very still
for me the nurse is going to help you
okay she's going to help me hold your
legs still and if you want to scream and
yell you can't okay
daryl don't yell yet it's my time
now yelp
he's almost finished here
all done all done honey
oh that sweetheart
[Music]
here's the band-aid hold the band-aid
for me can you open the band-aid up
open the band-aid
[Music]
[Music]
daryl is asking for his diaper from home
[Music]
[Music]
okay
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
see uncle pat got you a nice present no
okay don't open it
[Applause]
[Music]
me
hey
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i think he's gonna be peter's mother has
told the doctor that she hopes peter can
go home the following day
don't you think yeah well you know maybe
tomorrow afternoon if he's alright
tomorrow all right fine just you know
let me know will you need much notice i
mean if you when you come in to see him
tomorrow we say it's okay
robin is asking for her bottle okay
let me see him
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i could see the nurses
just make sure to set her up when she
has it
[Music]
i want you to drink some juice and try
to pee-pee for mommy okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Applause]
[Music]
all the parents left for the evening
while their children were dozing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you want a bottle of
ginger ale you want some ginger ale in a
bottle
will you drink it yeah okay
here you go
[Music]
[Music]
wanna go to
don't you stay up for a bed it's morning
let's go find your breakfast
you must have some don't you think
and get orson's
[Music]
[Music]
you want to eat right here all by
yourself yes
peter wants his breakfast on the sun
porch it's off a big table why don't you
come out meet with the other kids
[Music]
ready
oh
come on
[Music]
nothing
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
the secretary on the floor
no
robin
what's the matter
come on let me love you like mama come
on
huh
nothing not one thing i can do to make
you happy
what's the matter robin
i know you miss your
[Music]
wash mom eyes
okay what's your other one
good boy wash your ears
wash your ears
brush your ears just like that
okay wash your other ear
that's boy okay
good boy
dry
drawers
[Applause]
[Music]
that's my hair and i want it back i
don't want you wearing here so you'll
get down in here
[Music]
[Music]
and the fiddle the cow
jumped over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay play for a while peter and then
we'll get you washed up no
no
i have one
[Music]
[Music]
don't forget your chin
okay let me help you okay
and you can go back out the porch do you
like it out on the porch yeah why do you
like it there
you go
hmm
i need your own porch do you have you
have a porch at home
no
not at all not even for the summertime
[Music]
daryl's parents brought him another
diaper from home
[Music]
peter are you happy now
yeah
a little while he was crying you know
but then i told him you'd come in later
he settled down
please don't think you're gonna come to
see me okay
let me put your stickers on huh
i want you to try and bring someone from
a cup and then afterwards we'll put the
rest of your bottles you can't drink
from a cup okay
okay like all the other kids
you want okay i got an idea wrong you
want to sit on my lap and drink it
you just said you wanted some milk
didn't you
do you want a new
bottle you want the bottle you can't
drink any of it from the cup
you want to try a little bit
can you hold it
show me if you can hold it
you won't drink anything all right
[Music]
[Music]
let me see how it works watch mommy show
you drop it on the floor it'll bounce
drop it on the floor
drop it on the floor
see
you like that
i have a surprise for you after you each
dinner
all right
a new pair of pajamas for robin
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
um
[Music]
the wood chopper saw the wolf and what
did he do he
jumped over right he chopped the wolf up
and there was no more water right in
poor little red riding hood
yeah yeah it's not a sad story is he
going home tomorrow just check on his
tent
all right and with you here i'll take
her stressing off oh fine
oh you're a coward
i would have taken
a team to submit right
put your slinky in the band again
peter's doctor agreed to let him go home
the day after surgery
that's it the rest of stuff we'll leave
here
now leave that here i'll leave that to
cheryl and i'll buy you another one when
we get home i'll buy you one in cafe no
no
no
i'll buy you all right do you want to
take the time i'll take him
robin and daryl will stay another night
in the hospital
what is this
[Music]
robin asked to go to the bathroom
while she is there her mother leaves for
the evening telling the nurse she is
going
wow
[Music]
okay
oh
what's your name
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
i'm not going
oh
[Music]
daryl's mother hangs her coat behind the
curtain
tells him they are just going for water
and then they leave
[Music]
mommy
[Music]
the grandmother of another patient
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mommy and daddy are gonna come take you
home
but you have to wait for them
[Music]
mommy and daddy are gonna come take you
home
[Music]
you don't make me a funny face
can you kiss
you want to give me a kiss don't you
like me um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
you don't want to stay here no more
right
yes
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay
here this is yours too
okay
bye
you going home robin
fuzzy world
[Music]
i'm not going to get your shoes you get
your own shoes
[Applause]
in there all right
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
robin no not all that much too much
for some of that
[Music]
oh
almonds
you